- If somebody said,
"Predict what your grandchildren
do for a living."
I would say one of them
is 100% a psychologist,
because they will take my DNA,
but they will be part of
a rich family; which means
they have to be a psychologist.
And, the reason I say this,
so they can watch and be like,
"Fuck."
(hip hop music)
- [Man] You've got your perspective.
- [Robotic Voice] I just want to be happy.
I want respect.
(hip hop beats)
- Here in London,
early morning,
Andy K is here.
Which is, rare to see him
outside of that little
eight foot area.
(jazz music plays)
- D-Rock and I were just talking.
We put up like seven of like
nine videos on Instagram
over the last week.
Hit up over a million views,
which is incredibly strong
metrics for my page.
And, literally two days ago
in the office,
I'm like,
"Guys, we've got this totally
fucking figured out."
And, no joke, yesterday we posted...
Oh hey, Ryan just packaged something.
Ugh, yesterday literally,
we posted the worst performing
video we've posted and...
What's up brother?
Yeah, I'll see you in a little bit.
Head of Finance here in London.
Literally the worst piece of
fucking content we've put up.
Two things on that:
One, that's why this games the best
and confidence, humility, algorithms,
audience, putting out content,
highs, lows, we all go through them.
I...I was telling the guys,
"I loved it."
So...I love getting punched in the mouth.
More importantly,
number two,
when I posted it,
I knew it wasn't going to
overly perform.
Intuitively, this is just not the
kind of stuff that goes
viral on Instagram,
but it was probably one of the more
important pieces of content I've put out.
Of like, the balance of like,
optimism and actually putting in the work.
And, it reminded me of
the Thank You Economy.
My least selling book that I've written
but, arguably to me, philosophically,
the most important book I've written.
So...
What's up, my man?
- Sorry if I'm interrupting.
- No worries, no.
This is it.
This is it, you'll be in it.
- Nice meeting you man.
- That's just how sometimes it works.
Depth, a lot of times,
is way more meaningful to width.
And I just really wish more people
would wrap their head around it.
Especially in the context
of a post on Instagram.
Where the fuck does
that mean in your life?
Being upset all day because you didn't
get enough likes or reviews is stupid.
(hip hop beats)
- [Narrator] You guys, you do...
you do agree with me that we haven't spent
enough time talking about the fact that my
college went out of business.
It folded.
After 100 plus years,
it doesn't exist.
(hip hop beats)
- The biggest thing, Robbie,
that you guys need to think about is,
none of this is contextualized for
a different economy and that's the best
part of this whole thing.
Everything you just said is awesome
- [Man] Yeah.
- It becomes awesome when everything melts
and there is no side funds for four years.
And everyone is dying,
because what ends up happening,
just to tell you how it is going to
actually play out,
is this will all work
better because people
are going to make smarter decisions,
because they don't have the money
to make dumb decisions
and as it gets more money,
its going to self fund itself,
to be able to buy things that are of...
Do you know how many of these brands are
going to go out of business?
They're over leveraged.
(Rap Music)
- So, here's what's going to happen,
when the world melts,
At&t and BMW and Evian and Tesco
are all going to hire VaynerMedia.
Because, what's going to happen
is their marketing budgets going to go
from 100 million to 12 and they're going
to need that 12 to work really hard.
And we're established as knowing how to
do that and the only
reason people don't go
with us now, is because money is easy and
they don't have to do
the right work, so they
can give their money to their buddy or
the person that takes them to fucking the
Manchester United game on the field.
Got it?
When they can't do that anymore,
they're going to give it all to us.
I'm going to get all that,
so this machine that is stupid now,
gets really smart because we'll go
from 280 to 590 in revenue in 24 months.
It will be profitable revenue,
because the world will melt and
I'll be able to hire all the people
from other agencies for
25 cents on the dollar.
At the same time,
a bunch of companies are going
to be over leveraged and are going to
go out of business and I'm going to
buy those businesses with the cash
flow of the 590 at higher revenue.
Then, the economy will turn back in
twelve years and I'll be able to sell
those businesses at the frothy end
and buy the jets.
(group laughs)
- [Female] What's
happening after the jets?
- Super bowls.
You see what I'm doing?
I'm playing the reverse game.
So, everybody thinks it's stupid now,
because they don't understand
that it is over valued,
then it's going to seem very smart.
And then I'm going to be able to show
this video and be like,
"It wasn't an accident."
- [Female] Yeah.
- Which will only
compound the smarts of it
and I'll be 62 and have 40 years to play.
All on the equity of pulling off a billion
dollar thing on small smarts, not luck.
On humility of eating shit for a decade
in my prime, right?
Kids are going to watch these videos
and he was 39.
He was 42.
I'm 26 and he was patient
and that's why it worked.
I'm going to do that.
Nobodies ever seen anybody play it.
We didn't get to watch Steve Jobs's
first nine years and not that it matters,
this and that.
We didn't get to see Bezo's packing books.
Do you know how powerful it would be,
right now?
How many views do you think?
- [Male] 89
- How many views do you think,
if Jeff Basils was doing a blog,
those first fifty episodes of him
packing books in a
fucking garage would have?
- 80 million, maybe 14 billion?
Right?
Everybody would watch it.
I mean, everybody.
- [Male] Yeah.
- Yeah, so...
How'd you like to watch Michael Jordan's
first three off seasons
and the work he put in?
So, there's a lot of
thought that goes into
what I do, that I don't speak about or
I show glimpses of in things like this.
My team talks a lot about like me not
talking about being smart.
As you guys know,
none of my content is
predicated on being smart.
That's just going to speak for itself
when it's all said and done.
I don't need people to think I'm smart.
(hip hop music with lyrics)
- Oh God.
I couldn't...
I couldn't hate the current state
of education more.
I, I...the level of disrespect
I have for it is extraordinary.
All their...
The only good places are trading on brand
and it's because of the insecurity of
the professors of not
realizing they can do
it themselves direct to consumer.
Which, only has another ten years.
There is no Cambridge.
There is no Harvard.
There are the individuals
teaching within it
and the second that they wake up
and realize they have the leverage,
is the same reason I think the NBA
could actually fold.
I am in such...
I have a crazy thesis on the NBA.
I think the NBA is so top heavy to
the top fifteen stars and that they sit
with all the leverage.
That, if you look at them now.
If you look at the LeBron and
Dewade and these guys,
and right...
They're all friends,
they're all doing business together.
They're different than what I grew
up with Larry Bird and Jordan,
where they hated each other.
I think the next version is they're
going to condelude and break the league.
Right now, if LeBron down to Greek Freak,
the 12 best players in the league,
also then paired up with a billionaire
and said, "Let's start a new league.
I'm LeBron, you're Russian
Olegard, I'm Kevin Durant,
you're a tech...
You're Mark Zuckerburg, lets...
We're going to leave and we're going
to start a new NBA.
I own 50 percent of the team as LeBron.
You own 50 percent of
the team Kevin Sistran.
We're now the Los Angeles Loop Hole and
all you need left, the only thing left,
is just having a stadium
that will take you.
And, that's where some of
the teams control that.
Other than that, they
actually have no leverage.
That is not true in proper football.
That is not true in baseball.
That is not true in a lot of places.
In the NBA it is.
And it is the strength of the NBA
and it will be the demise of the NBA.
I'm 100 percent right about this.
It's inevitable.
It has to happen.
What is most interesting to me,
is when the stuff has happened,
but people don't see it yet;
but, you don't even have to guess.
Shopify and Amazon has happened.
Yet, they don't believe it's happened.
It's in your face.
People always ask me, "What's next?"
I'm like, "I have no idea."
But, the second I see it,
I will probably be the fastest
and loudest to talk about it.
And then,
you think I'm guessing or predicting.
I watched Snapchat for fifteen months
before I publicly went on
the, "Snapchat is here."
And everyone in the
marketing world is like,
"He was the one that was
right about Snapchat."
Fifteen months, I analyzed it.
And then only after the DJ Khalid moment,
because I knew it was going to hit the
Zietgiest, that I got in front of it.
I watched Twitch from the day it started.
Literally Justin texted me because he did
Justin TV, when he started Twitch.
I've been watching it, but only did
I start talking about it, because I was
forced to, because fucking Ninja and Drake
had the moment and now I knew it was
going to be in the Zietgiest.
I'll watch the whole
time and I'll only start
speaking about my
thoughts if I'm forced to,
because I know the world had tipped.
Or, I've put the container around it
to then talk about it.
- [Man] That's the trend
spotting, isn't it?
- 100 percent. It's what
I'm really darn good at.
If somebody asked me to
tell me what might...
If somebody said predict
what your grandchildren
do for a living, I
would say one of them is
100 percent a psychologist.
Because they will take my DNA,
but they will be apart of a rich family,
which means they have
to be a psychologist,
not an entrepreneur.
Positive.
Just the way it all works out.
- [Man] It's written in the stars.
- Written in it.
And the reason I say this
is so they can watch it
and be like, "Fuck."
(laughing)
- [Man] How did he know that shit?
- I think I'm going to make my family into
entrepreneurs in perpetuity
out of being shamed
of not doing the cliche shit
I'm telling them their going to do.
(laughing)
(hip hop beats)